ها هي خريطتنا القديمة وإليكم الخريطة الجديدة ،
حسنًا أولاً ، دعنا
نلقي نظرة على تلك الخريطة الجديدة كما قال كريج
إننا كنا نقود ونحلق في جميع
أنحاء الولايات المتحدة
لجمع البيانات الأرضية والجوية لإضافة
تفاصيل جديدة مهمة إلى الخريطة  لذا الآن
تبدو الحدائق والمباني على الطرق والشواطئ رائعة ،
لقد أضفنا أيضًا بعض
الميزات الجديدة المفيدة جدًا إلى
شاشة الإطلاق المصممة حديثًا مثل المفضلة حيث يمكنني
إضافة الأماكن التي أذهب إليها كل يوم للوصول السريع
والسهل الآن يمكنني فقط النقر فوق
واذهب مع المجموعات ، فهذه
هي المكان الذي يمكنني فيه تنظيم كل ما لدي من
مفضلات أو يمكنني إنشاء قوائم
مفضلة لمشاركتها مع الأصدقاء أو يمكنني
أخيرًا تنظيم تلك الرحلة الكبيرة التالية ،
دعنا نتحقق من مجموعة مواقع SF الخاصة بي
الآن لقد كنت أتحقق  خارج الحي الصيني ،
ستلاحظ في الزاوية اليمنى
العلوية وجود زر مناظير جديد
عندما أضغط على أن أحصل على نظرة جديدة تمامًا
حول النافذة ، نعم هذا هو
المكان المناسب لإسقاطه ، لذا سأذهب إلى وضع ملء
الشاشة بنظرة  و أحصل على
عرض ثلاثي الأبعاد رائع وعالي الدقة ، إنها
طريقة رائعة للاستكشاف
ولكن هذا هو الجزء المفضل لدي ، اقلب
هاتفك وأمسكه بإحكام ، تحرك بسلاسة
إلى أسفل الشارع ، نعم لم تره
هكذا [تصفيق]